so you've probably heard about climate
change just about everywhere but what
exactly is climate change well on a very
basic level it's the world heating up
climate change is a very complex B slope
with hundreds of factors but let's talk
about the fundamental cause at the root
of it all carbon dioxide or co2 carbon
dioxide is a naturally occurring gas
it's inside all of us and everywhere
around us so why is everyone so up in
arms about it well for hundreds of
thousands of years the co2 levels in the
atmosphere have been relatively stable
hovering around 250 parts per million or
ppm or with the Industrial Revolution in
the past few hundred years and the
drastic increase in the burning of
fossil fuels this has caused the co2
levels to shoot up to around 390 parts
per million this is bad because carbon
dioxide behaves like a greenhouse
letting heat from the Sun into the
Earth's atmosphere very easily but
making it very hard for it to escape
while co2 is the biggest contributor to
the greenhouse effect other gases come
into play as well
these are methane nitrous oxide and
Kluber fluorocarbon or CFC all of which
have an effect on climate change the
biggest human cause of climate change is
the burning of fossil fuels to generate
energy the same energy you use every
time you switch a light on 65 percent of
carbon emissions come from the burning
of fossil fuels 21 percent of carbon
emissions come from transport and 7
percent comes from methane emissions
from agriculture livestock going about
their business and the rest comes from
various of resources but here's the
kicker humans only contribute around
0.28 percent of global greenhouse gases
the rest comes from natural sources such
as volcanoes and the oceans of course
they don't tell you that on the news
because it's much less terrifying and
nobody would care about climate change
anymore but if human contributions is so
small why should we care well the truth
is 0.28% is terrifying and you have good
reason to be worried since the formation
of the earth greenhouse gases have been
in a fine balance massive amounts of
gases
mostly methane have been constantly
released from volcanic eruptions for
over 4.5 four billion years but most of
these harmful gases have been absorbed
back into the oceans stopping any
greenhouse effects from kicking in and
snowballing but in the short time that
humans have been emitting greenhouse
gases we have pushed to levels over the
edge it's like the straw breaking the
camel's back that small 0.28 percent of
greenhouse gases is enough to send the
co2 levels into harmful amount resulting
in exponentially increasing co2 levels
humans are producing more carbon and the
oceans can handle the oceans can only
absorb so much carbon so the remainder
is sent into the atmosphere and when
that happens you're gonna have a bad
time all of these effects are compounded
by the rapid deforestation of the
Earth's rain forests since trees
directly reverse the effects of global
warming by taking in carbon dioxide and
releasing oxygen through a process
called photosynthesis the more trees we
cut down the less co2 is removed from
the atmosphere and this results in a
vicious cycle and rapidly increasing co2
levels that's all for part one but in
part two of climate change I'll be
talking about some of the scariest
outcomes of global warming
you